[Musique]
Stéphanie Grammond Émilie Nicolas
Christian Dufour bonsoir à vous trois
bonsoir bonsoir crise ou partie libérale
du Québec vous venez d'entendre madame
anglais qui dit je veux rester et dis
pas clairement j'ai fait une erreur mais
on comprend que les lignes
et là il veut convaincre sa député une
fois de l'avoir sorti qu'elle rentre que
va faire madame Nicole c'est une
question tout le temps rapide première
réaction c'est quand même étonnant tout
ce qui est arrivé depuis quatre jours
oui Stéphanie pardonnez-moi
oui ben c'est absolument étonnant on
peine à imaginer en fait on dirait que
Madame Anglade est dans le déni depuis
le
jour des élections en fait est monté sur
la scène mais on avait l'impression
qu'elle était victorieuse alors que en
réalité il a perdu des voix ils étaient
à 25 % en 2018 ils sont rangés à 14% en
quatrième position derrière la non
seulement la carte mais le Parti
québécois et Québec solidaire ils ont
perdu ils avaient 31 députés ils étaient
rendus à 21 et là il se permettent d'en
perdre une c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
terrible pour eux et puis en plus madame
Nico ce qui a été mise à la porte elle
était dans vos oreilles c'était une des
rares circonscriptions libérales à
l'extérieur de l'île de Montréal en fait
ça se comptait sur les doigts de la main
et puis là ben on enlève une donc ça
fait d'autant plus mal et bon c'est bien
sûr là dit on va la réintégrer d'accord
mais ça va laisser des blessures on peut
pas laisser on peut pas laver son linge
sur la place publique comme ça sans que
ça sans que ça laisse des traces
à la question que je lui ai posé est-ce
que vous allez vous excuser auprès de
Madame Nico privé mais moi si j'avais
été exclu d'un caucus comme ça comme ça
la première des choses qu'on demande
c'est des excuses on aurait pas dû agir
aussi vite Emilie Nicolas qu'en
pensez-vous
c'est intéressant de voir ça aller parce
que du côté de Québec solidaire par
exemple ou du Parti québécois bien sûr
on a obtenu pas mal moins de députés
après la dernière élection mais
l'ambiance est pas du tout la même
pourquoi parce qu'au partis libérale on
a l'habitude du pouvoir on a l'habitude
de gagner et je pense que quand ça quand
on est plus loin du pouvoir l'ambiance
est complètement différente je pense
qu'on a affaire un focus qui
essentiellement se pense avoir le droit
de former un gouvernement jusqu'à un
certain point et ça se met à brasser
quand il y a pas les résultats
électoraux qui veulent je pense que le
Parti libéral est un parti pas
l'habitude de garder aussi des chefs qui
ont pas remporté une victoire électorale
donc le ton monte je pense que quand on
monte on a tendance à tester les limites
on saura jamais on sera jamais dans
Secret des yeux savoir comment est-ce
que la conversation s'est passée au
curcus mais il me semble que justement
quand on est fâché de pas avoir un
meilleur résultat électoral on peut
peut-être même tester un peu plus ses
limites l'autorité de la chair et ça
donne des situations qui sont plus
difficiles à négocier ou essentiellement
c'est un bon français une demi filou
d'amifie donc là si si on laisse les
gens du marché dessus ben on perd notre
autorité puis si les gens qui est à
cause de ça on part aussi notre autorité
donc je pense que je pense que le climat
général à l'intérieur du parti libérale
même Dominique Anglade dans une
situation à peu près impossible à gérer
ça c'est intéressant vous souligner ça
parce que on ne sait pas effectivement
peut-être que l'attitude de Madame
Nicole était pas on ne pouvait une chef
ne pouvait pas accepter que Madame
d'accord je ne prendrai aucune
responsabilité alors mais qu'on arrive
pas
à trouver une entente un chemin c'est là
le problème est qu'on aille jusqu'à
l'expulsion qui est une réelle
confrontation la limite que la chef est
eu raison
à la fin de la journée Christian c'est
quand même la chèvre que Dieu expulsé et
là voyant la réaction chez les militants
d'anciens ministres du bonheur vient
donc d'abord
frappé dans l'entrevue que Madame
anglaise vous consacré c'est son
incapacité viscérale admettre que le feu
une erreur comme si c'était honteux
donc ça donne des interventions qui font
très longues de bois il faut trouver une
issue faut focaliser sur le positif si
tu seras pratique que ça de dire oui je
fais une erreur et puis je je m'en
serais les conséquences pour l'avenir le
problème c'est que le Parti libéral est
dans une situation objectivement très
très difficile ce grand parti québécois
historique et devenu un peu le parti des
Anglais comment le sortir de ce cul de
sa cloque comment te faire en sorte que
la marque libérale reprennent un peu
d'intérêt pour les franc francophones
donc pour faire ça il faut un chef il
faut un leader extrêmement talentueux et
là vraiment il faut se poser des
questions sur l'attitude de Madame
Anglade a réussi à ce Paris-là choisi
moi j'enterre pas trop vite les chefs de
parti souvenons-nous de Paul
Saint-Pierre timbandon qu'on a
est-ce que elle sera d'abord en principe
c'est dans un an de confiance
sera-t-elle d'après vous à son vote de
confiance dans un tour de table rapide
de Stéphanie
moi il me semble que ça va être
extrêmement difficile si j'étais à sa
place je voudrais régler ça au plus vite
parce que sinon ça va revenir sur le
tapis cette question là constamment et
ça va miner les les possibilités du
parti libérale de penser à autre chose
et puis de mettre de l'avant les vrais
enjeux qui qui doivent être mis devant
Émilie Nicolas ce qu'elle peut nous
surprendre que tel un chat avec
plusieurs vies ou d'après vous ça va
être très difficile de se rendre dans un
an au vote de confiance ça dépend de
l'actualité il y a des sujets où elle
ressort de manière plus forte donc c'est
la réalité c'est la qualité portait sur
des sujets ou un peu ressortir son
épingle du jeu peut-être ceci dit j'ai
trouvé ça intéressant qu'à souligne les
en fait les défis logistiques à
organiser un congrès des membres je
pense que le sous-tex derrière ça c'est
qu'en fait plusieurs personnes dans à la
permanence du parti dans dans son équipe
qui vient de démissionner aussi donc
même la capacité du parti organisa
congrès des membres quand le les
employés les plus seniors sont en train
de de quitter le poste des défis à ce
niveau là donc je pense qu'il y a
vraiment des grandes conversations à
voir à l'interne dans les prochains mois
pour même avoir l'équipe en place pour
organiser
de leadership c'est le test de sa vie
moi comme j'ai dit je les interprète
trop vite j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
les gens qui font de la politique mais
si je me fie à l'entrevue elle vient de
vous donner je veux pessimiste parce que
tout ça c'est les menteur de notre
capable de dire que oui alors tout le
monde c'est le serpent marcher mais là
on est dans l'avenir pour pouvoir faire
d'autres choses je trouve que quand tu
es dans la langue de bois tu perds
beaucoup de crédibilité puis comme si
c'est les dans la langue de bois alors
que son défi c'est pas en fait de de me
dire des choses sur eux c'est d'être à
la hauteur du défi énorme qui est
objectivement le siècle librement
libéral j'aurais bon ben là par contre
je défie il me faudrait peut-être avoir
quelqu'un d'autre mais il y en a
plusieurs qui commencent et à le dire
publiquement le sans cacher leur nom
alors on verra la suite des choses le
Parti conservateur du Québec qui faisait
un post mortem samedi de cette campagne
électorale et quelques jours auparavant
sur notre site ailleurs on pouvait lire
déchirement on
furieux et tout ça et c'est un peu
surréaliste parce que Monsieur devient
m'a quand même pour mémoire c'est un
fait pris un parti qui était à 0,4 puis
il l'a amené à 14% à peu près là donc
mais on va écouter monsieur qui dit
c'est vrai qu'il faut faire des
ajustements et tout ça je vais vous
écouter là-dessus mais quand je peux
comparer je me console on l'écoute
quand je me regarde je me désole quand
je me compare je me console quand je
vois que Dominique anglais de perdre son
organisateur en chef elle vient de
mettre une députée dehors à le perdre du
sang directeur des communications quand
je regarde monsieur le goût aussi avec
un paquet de députés qui sont pas très
heureux de pas faire partie du conseil
des ministres je pense que nos problèmes
sont relatifs par rapport aux autres
mais il y a reconnu Christian je donne
la parole il a reconnu que oui bien sûr
qu'il y avait des problèmes
d'organisation que
c'était presque miracle qui est parti à
travers la campagne
ouais je trouve que ça va vraiment très
bien pour eux ça fait un gros contraste
avec les libéraux Dominique Anglade
parce que après l'élection que qui a été
pour lui un résultat crève-cœur parce
que pas été capable de lire un sol
député parce qu'ils pouvaient craindre
c'est que en fait notre système
politique l'ignore parce qu'on sait que
les hommes au départ très valorisé par
la plupart des commentateurs et des
chroniqueurs alors depuis l'élection il
est pas du tout ignorée on parle
systématiquement de lui et le congrès de
la fin de semaine en fait pour lui c'est
bien bon quel bilan que les gens qui
critiquent c'est pas grave c'est que
leur modéré ce matin je vous donne une
émission de te connaître
en radicalisation Université de
Sherbrooke qui disait qu'actuellement
sur les réseaux sociaux la personne qui
est le plus critiqué dans les
complotistes c'est irrituel c'est très
bon pour lui en demander parce que ça
c'est ça donc c'est dans une bonne chose
parce que on sent d'ailleurs parce que
on parle de lui il fait important qu'on
parle de lui puis quelque part il y a
l'air modéré par rapport à une partie ça
gagne qui peut être franchement un peu
inquiète
durant la campagne électorale je me
souviens de Éric Duhem qui disait qui
voulait faire entrer la grenouillement
c'est à dire une station qui avait
beaucoup fait
parler puis c'est un peu comme si la
grogne sur laquelle il le surfait ou la
colère populaire sur lequel qui a voulu
arnasser être entré en partie de se
retourner vers lui du moins il me semble
avoir de la difficulté à avoir la main
sur sur une partie de ces membres je
pense que dans les prochains mois
justement bloqué pour Parlement il y a
tout le loisirs d'aller faire la tournée
dans les régions pour parler à ses
membres mais reste que c'est un
mouvement qui est basé qui est vraiment
mouvement en fait qui est basé sur sur
un mouvement protestataire sur une
colère et c'est pas difficile c'est pas
facile c'est à dire à gérer c'est pas
facile à transformer ce genre de
mouvance là en partie politique qui va
faire des assemblées générales et des
congrès et des assemblées c'est très
c'est très difficile comme conversion
puis je pense qu'il semble être aux
prises avec ce défi là et il y a une
partie des gens pour qui je pense qu'ils
vont constater que l'exercice normal de
la politique ne les intéresse pas et
puis une partie qui va rester oui un peu
comme GQS mais à gauche où il y a une il
y a encore une crise de croissance puis
en seulement de ce qu'on quel élément
plus à gauche on enlève ou pas de la
plateforme du programme etc c'est Fanny
Gramont mais c'est sûr qu'il y a ce
phénomène là mais en même temps monsieur
dum lui a beaucoup misé sur la colère
des de ces de ses membres face aux
mesures sanitaires face à la pandémie et
donc
il s'est retrouvé à avoir une base qui
était à 50% constitué de gens qui qui
étaient complotistes de ce que les
sondages de ce qu'on avait comme
maintenant ces gens là si la pandémie
s'essouffle si les mesures sanitaires
disparaissent éventuellement est-ce que
est-ce qu'il va avoir encore autant de
souffle ça me paraît difficile c'est
vrai qu'il y ait réussi à aller chercher
13 % des voix c'est quand même étonnant
là qu'un parti en si peu de temps à
aller chercher une telle base mais ce
qui va rester à ce niveau-là ça va
dépendre du fait est-ce qu'il va pouvoir
prendre un virage avec vraiment des des
positions de droite plus plus affirmé
sur différents dossiers mais là pour
l'instant ce qu'il y avait dans sa
plateforme c'était pas très convaincant
juste une rectification parce que on
répète toujours ça en fait c'était René
c'est à partir d'une étude de
l'Université de Sherbrooke et qui disait
que c'est pas que 50% des supporters de
rhum sont complexes c'est 50% des gens
qui se disent complotistes votre épaule
c'est répéter sans ça c'est une erreur
assez fondamentale c'est clair que
sur le nouveau chemin Roxane je
simplifie ce sont des Mexicains qui
n'ont pas besoin de visa pour venir au
Canada qui prennent un avion et qui
arrivant à l'aéroport Trudeau demande le
statut de réfugiés il y en a eu 8000 on
peut voir la courbe c'est monté en
flèche
année après année et là vraiment c'est
un nouveau phénomène qui s'installe une
nouvelle faille selon plusieurs dans
dans le système d'entrée tour de table
Émilie Nicolas est-ce que est-ce que le
Canada va pas devoir revoir sa politique
de ne pas demander de visa mexicain
d'abord je pense qu'il faut faire très
attention avec la formule nouveau chemin
Roxane le chemin Roxane existe parce
qu'il y a une entente de cap et ici
entre le Canada et les États-Unis qui
fait que lorsqu'on est déjà aux
États-Unis on peut pas demander la
demande d'asile au Canada si on passe la
frontière de manière régulière sa force
les gens à passer la frontière de
manière irrégulière c'est pas quelque
chose d'illégal mais c'est irrégulier et
il y a tellement de en fait de
désinformation que c'est fait sur ces
questions là que je pense qu'il faut
faire très attention cette expression là
pour parler de gens qui essentiellement
font ce qu'on fait quand on fait une
demande d'asile c'est-à-dire venir à
l'aéroport et dire je demande l'asile au
Canada après la question c'est pourquoi
est-ce que les gens font se demandera
est-ce que ces gens-là vont être
acceptés ou non comme réfugiés sur
quelle base ça dépend combien de temps
prendra exactement puis là c'est une
situation qui est plus qui est plus
similaire à par exemple le cas des des
demandeurs d'asile haïtiens ou un pays
beaucoup de violence et beaucoup de
pauvreté beaucoup de chômage et donc il
y a des gens qui s'y viennent pour des
raisons économiques vont se faire
refuser le statut de réfugiés si ils ont
vraiment des qui sont capables de
prouver que leur vie est en danger à
savoir c'est vraiment des des réfugiés
au sens de la loi ils vont être acceptés
on peut y voir aussi un détournement de
l'immigration économique c'est des gens
qui normalement si le système est
marchait plus rondement pourrait
pour être postuler et avoir un permis de
travail au Canada Christian Dufour reste
peu de temps mais votre avis moi je
trouve que c'est le chemin Roxane qui
fait des petits parce que c'est un
système bien organisé comme le chemin
Roxane c'est pas des individus qui
arrive c'est un système c'est des
passages il y a de l'argent là-dedans il
y a de la bulle là-dedans moi ce que
j'espère c'est que doté de l'immigration
aussi que c'est très complexe mais le
dos aussi ce dos c'est le chemin Roxane
mais ce dos c'est là j'espère qu'il va
avoir un franc comme un très large au
Québec parce que c'est très mal c'est
vraiment abusé des Québécois ça passe
par le Québec essentiellement et à
Dorval et au chemin Roxane et moi tout
respect pour Émilie c'est vraiment le
chemin Roxane qui fait des petits parce
que c'est un système organisé partout
dans le monde d'après ce que je
comprends ça se sait de plus en plus on
peut aller au Canada en débutant les
règles allez-y ok on va reprendre ce
départ
qui ont sorti ça va reprendre ce débat à
Émilie et Stéphanie je vous le promets
très très bientôt
monsieur blanken disait la semaine
dernière c'est la plus grande pression
migratoire depuis que l'histoire
depuis qu'on a des livres donc lui dit
il faut remettre ça dans son contexte ou
si à très bientôt à vous trois on en
reparle au revoir bonne soirée bonsoir
bonsoir